foreign
let's move on to some social media
questions we have a question from
Instagram
Ali asks this year I'm opting out of a
secret Santa gift exchange at work
because there's nothing I want under ten
dollars and I don't want to stress over
a gift for a colleague I barely know why
does this make me feel like a killjoy
and how do I get over it
well you might be a killjoy to someone
else right you're always going to be a
kill joy to someone sure right yeah and
if we're going around attempting to
please everyone all the time we're going
to be fairly unpleasant to ourselves
and so
I think the reason you're having such a
problem with this is an obligatory gift
is actually a curse
if I'm forced if Ryan said in order for
me to be on this podcast Josh every
every Tuesday when we come in here and
do these live streams you have to bring
me a gift
I mean it'd be an obligation right right
and I would do it because he I want him
to be on the podcast so every Tuesday
I'm bringing him some sort of like tie
clip or cufflinks or sunglasses or a
gift card to Best Buy whatever it is and
I wouldn't feel great about it but also
you know what I don't think Ryan would
feel great about it either right because
he would at best he'd just begin to
expect it and if I didn't if I show up
one Tuesday without a gift
he'd like hey man where's my gift and he
would start to feel miserable because I
didn't give him the obligatory gift that
he requested and so
I think that
acceptance is what you're seeking here
through the gift giving process and
acceptance is a gift
of sorts
but needing their acceptance is a type
of curse if you're going into the work
or to any familial situation and I need
you to accept me in order for me to be
happy fulfilled content at peace
I'm never going to be at peace because
I'm constantly needing to do things I
have to prove myself my worth to you my
value to you through my works now I can
be valuable
I can accept you and I can really
appreciate your acceptance be grateful
for your acceptance but as soon as I
need it
that's not acceptance I'm not accepting
you I'm accepting the fact that there
are conditions here and I'm gonna have
to meet those conditions in order to get
your acceptance well is that even real
acceptance anyway
yeah I mean for me it sounds like Ali's
struggling with uh
feeling like they're adding value to
their colleagues
and I'll tell you uh under 10 secret
Santa gift is probably
you know the least value you could add
towards a colleague
so you know I would be asking the
question if if I was Ali about how am I
on a regular basis showing my colleagues
that I appreciate them what am I doing
for them or um what am I doing at my job
to show that I do really appreciate them
being my colleagues and if you're doing
that
um if I was doing that I wouldn't feel
so bad about not doing the 10 gift but I
mean if that's the only thing that
you're doing though I could see where
yeah maybe you feel like man I don't
really do anything for these these folks
the least I could do is do something
under ten dollars I mean if that's where
it's coming from I totally get the
sentiment um so then and that doesn't
mean to just give in and do the Secret
Santa but what that does mean is try to
find other ways to show everyone at work
that you appreciate them not just on
December 25th exactly and I know this
with Ryan his birthday was recently and
I don't know if I text you on the day of
but if I would have forgot
hey you wouldn't have cared
but B like I also wouldn't have felt bad
about it right or calling you whatever
because I go out of my way the other 364
days a year
to be a gift to you yeah and I'm happy
like just yesterday here's a great
example just yesterday Bex and I we gave
Ella a gift in the morning right before
I drove her to her unschool
um she comes out and there's this
wrapped gift in the kitchen she's like
oh is this Christmas
it's like like what did you just ask
I'm like no and she's like well why did
you get this for me I said well I don't
need a special day to give you a gift
I can give you a gift any day that feels
appropriate and she was all excited she
opened it up and it was like because
she's been asking for you know how I've
got that fleece that I wear in here it's
real like fuzzy on it's especially fuzzy
on the inside she always tries to wear
my fleece and so I got her this purple
fleece which you know purple's her
favorite color and so it's very similar
to mine except it's purple and I mean
she freaked out you would have thought I
got her a pony or something oh my
goodness and she puts it on right I'm
gonna wear it today I'm gonna wear it
every day and
I didn't need to wait until December
25th or wait until her birthday or some
special holiday to show her that I care
about her that I love her the reason
that we give gifts to someone is to add
value to their lives and a secret Santa
gift rarely adds any value to anyone's
life in fact it can extract value
because now I just spent 10 bucks I
spent a ton of time
and now I am forced to do this sort of
decorous dance with you here's your
little obligatory gift give me my
obligatory gift let me see if mine's
better than yours it becomes this
competition this comparison whereas with
what I was giving Ella I didn't expect
anything back here it is I'm giving you
something because I want to add value to
your life
yes you'll likely enjoy this and that's
wonderful but I don't need to give this
to you for your acceptance you already
have my acceptance I have yours
regardless of whether or not there's
some sort of material good being
exchanged yeah man this reminds me of
this time when um this guy offered us
cigarettes for her kids and the first
guy who was with us he took the
cigarette and held it in his hand then
then the guy offered one to my brother
and my brother says no I'm good and then
the other guy who took the cigarette was
like yeah I'm actually good too and then
the guy with the cigarettes didn't even
waste his time offering me one like you
immediately saw things turn around just
because one person was willing to say no
at the risk of being a killjoy right
it's not until you're willing to look
like a killjoy that you can actually
have the power to become a trendsetter
how many awesome things never come into
being because we're afraid that someone
else is going to ah look at us like
we're not fun oh don't be so serious you
know don't so serious just play the
Santa game don't be the one guy that
says you don't want to do it hey man I
may be serious to you I may be heavy to
you but I feel light to me because I'm
being true to who I want to be right and
so don't let other people hold you
Hostage to their personal concept of
what it means to be fun there are a lot
of people out there who will threaten
you like if you don't do what I want you
to do then I'm gonna label you as a
person that's not fun cool no problem
because I'd rather have fun being me
than look fun being who you want me to
be you know what I mean yeah well it's
interesting too because like technically
you can't really kill anyone's Joy if
someone is joyful yes I mean then
they're joyful yeah and it's it's
independent on how who someone else is
or how someone else is or what someone
else is doing if it is dependent on that
then I would you know posit that they're
actually not joyful
yeah yeah you saw the equalizer you
dressed like Denzel today you got the
haircut and everything
um there's a line in there so there's
two types of pain
right it's like the the pain that you
feel that you experience
and the pain that teaches you something
um
and this is a painful experience for Ali
right because it's like oh I'm gonna be
different they're gonna look at me
strange and there's some sort of pain
there right
and you can experience that and then say
oh I don't want to feel that pain again
I might as well conform I might as well
get the gifts because I don't want to
feel that pain or maybe it's the type of
pain where it's
ah yeah
I'm gonna feel this because it's gonna
teach me something it's going to teach
me I don't need to give someone a gift
to prove my worth to prove my love to
prove my position
among my friends my co-workers
Etc I can simply show up and be me
and if someone is expecting more than me
out of me then that that's their problem
for their expectations I can't kill your
joy if you're joyful You're simply
joyful now I can do things that might
amplify your life or enhance your
experience of life but it's not possible
for me to be your joy did you enjoy this
Standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalists private podcasts available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free